روسيا والجماعات المسلحه التابعه لها في
قائمه الدول والكيانات التي تنتهك حقوق
الاطفال في النزاعات المسلحه بسبب هجماتها
على المدارس والمستشفيات وقتل الاطفال
بالارقام يقول غوتيريش ان الامم المتحده
تحققت من مقتل 136 طفلا وتشويه خمسمائه
وثمانيه عشر طفلا على يد القوات الروسيه
والقوات التابعه لها خلال العام الماضي
غوتيريش مصدوم من العدد الكبير للانتهاكات
لجسيمه ضد الاطفال في اوكرانيا والتي لا
تمثل حتى النطاق الكامله للحوادث في
المقابل يقرر بوتيرش عدم ادراج اوكرانيا
على قائمه الدول والكيانات التي تنتهك
حقوق الاطفال في النزاعات المسلحه لكن
تقريره يوثق مقتل 80 طفلا وتشويه
175 على يد القوات الاوكرانيه خلال العام
الماضي اما بالنسبه لاسرائيل فان تقرير
الامين العام للامم المتحده يوثق قتلها
لاثنين واربعين طفلا فلسطينيا
وتشويها 370 ويقول التقرير ان مستوطنا
اسرائيليا قتل طفلا فلسطينيا خلال عام
غوتيرش منزعج للغايه من استمرار ارتفاع
مستوى الانتهاكات الجسيمه ضد الاطفال
باستعمال الذخيره الحيه واذا استمرار
انعدام المساءله عن هذه الانتهاكات رغم
ذلك يتجنب الامين العام للامم المتحده
ادراج اسرائيل على قائمه الدول والكيانات
التي تنتهك حقوق الاطفال ويقول انه لاحظ
انخفاضا ملموسا في الاطفال الذين قتلوا
وشوهوا على يد القوات الاسرائيليه مقارنه
بتقريره السابق لكن العام الماضي كان
الاكثر دمويه بالنسبه للاطفال الفلسطينيين
منذ 15 عاما بحسب هيومن رايت وترى المنظمه
انا عادما رغبه الامين العام في محاسبه
القوات الاسرائيليه على انتهاكاتها
الجسيمه شجعها على استخدام القوه المميته
ضد الاطفال الفلسطينيين الامين العام الحق
الضرر بالاطفال في فلسطين بعدم ادراج
اسرائيل في القائمه السوداء تقول المنظمه